l'arrivée d'une nouvelle renault c'est
toujours un événement celle que nous
découvrons aujourd'hui porte le
matricule numéro 9 et se place entre la
5 et la 18 pour remplacer à long terme
la 14
une voiture qui bénéficie d'une
construction automatisé à l'extrême dans
l' usine de douai ou 125 robots
permettent de gagner 5 heures sur un
temps de montage conventionnel un bel
exploit à la japonaise
d'emblée renoue présente une gamme
complète une seule carrosserie
certes mais trois moteurs 3 transmission
et quatre niveaux d'équipement soit un
choix d'une dizaine de modèles
quand sera disponible la boîte
automatique au printemps prochain
[Musique]
la voiture est défini sur une ligne
classique dit à trois volumes bien
équilibrée mais peu original la malle de
bonne contenance offre plus de 400
litres grâce au mini encombrement de
l'essieu arrière
[Musique]
classique également le tableau de bord
type frigo ou 18
mais l'originalité ce sont les sièges
avant ancré sur des glissières très
rapproché ils permettent aux passagers
arrière détendre un peu plus leurs
jambes et celui du conducteur bénéficie
de trois réglages translation avoir hier
inclinaison du dossier bien sûr mais
aussi pivotement générale de l'ensemble
du siège coquille très agréable et
confortable
renom adopte enfin le vrai moteur
transversal pour cette traction avant ce
sont des blocs déjà connu 11 200 et 400
centimètres cubes un peu anciens mais si
économique et aujourd'hui avec allumage
électronique
[Musique]
cela fait trois degrés de motorisation
47 chevaux et demi avec le 11 cents et
60 ou 62 chevaux en 14 cents
première conclusion de notre essai la
définition de nouvelles suspensions à
quatre roues indépendantes a permis
enfin de supprimer le roux les
classiques des renault en virage de plus
une direction merveilleuse de douceur et
de pression améliore un bilan routier
globale qui n'affecte en rien le confort
traditionnel renault
douceur et précision également avec la
commande de boîte 4 ou 5 vitesses
la plus réussie de la régie
pas de défaut rien n'est parfait et nous
lui avons reproché d'être un peu
sensibles au vent bruyante à haut régime
et parfois instable au freinage car les
modèles de base n'ont pas de régulateur
de frein arrière
mais la grande force de l'a9 c'est
d'offrir en quatre mètres de long un
compromis performances consommation
absolument remarquable cilic 6 en
moyenne 11 cents cette gamme qui ont
l'ambition de décrocher entre 8 et 10%
du marché français s'échelonnent de
35000 9 à 46 1500 francs
[Musique]